we are focusing on a story we first
reported on monday about the search for
the right kind of baby formula for you
and your baby families in the u.s spend
more than four billion dollars a year on
formula and parents in some parts of the
country are struggling to find their
preferred brand on store shelves
well there's a new style of organic
formula called bobby and it is changing
the industry with its american-made
european style should say so-called
european style formula that is the first
to be fda approved
bobby had more than 18 million dollars
in sales in its first year and it is the
fastest growing infant formula to enter
the american market in decades
laura modi the ceo and one of its
co-founders is a mother of three and for
modi and her team of employees creating
this organic formula was a personal
journey here's the story of kim a bobby
employee this is what my freezer supply
looks like
running out i finally had a bit of a
breakdown at about nine months
and said i think i need to supplement
formula i don't know why i feel so bad
cause i've tried so hard
i remember feeling
so
guilty
that i was not able to give her breast
milk because i had to choose work and my
family
over being able to exclusively
breastfeed her
and bobby co-founder laura modi joins us
now laura thank you for being here thank
you yeah we're glad to have you yeah we
really appreciate it uh i think i get
the honor of asking the first question
because we are a bobby household
although i guess
kirby i have to say is a bobby household
too so i'm very familiar with this
product yeah we love you laura we do
we're big fans there's nothing you are
changing the world to know that we are
feeding babies yes
you just heard kim's personal story but
you have a personal story here as well
you were struggling with breastfeeding
and you found yourself at a convenience
store didn't like what you saw take us
take us there look when you've got three
kids under five there is nothing more
personal than this
i thought i would breastfeed i thought
it would be the most easy beautiful
experience you would ever go through i
mean of course becoming a mother you
think this is natural i should be able
to do this but no i'm standing in the
middle of a pharmacy choosing a product
that felt like i mean honestly the
complete antithesis to breast milk
cradled between cat food and diapers
and i'm reading the back of the label
first ingredient is corn syrup and
saying i wouldn't feed this to myself
why am i going to feed this to my
newborn
and that was really the genesis to get
bobby off the ground and actually got to
feed it to my own babies afterwards so
what does it mean for the formula to be
european style
well
first you need to understand the
differences between u.s and eu formulas
and it really is it comes down to the
nutritional standards so in the eu their
nutritional standards get updated on a
fairly regular basis the last time was
in 2019
in comparison to the us the last time
the nutritional standards were updated
were in the 1980s
wow so the the other what i keep hearing
about what what's so great is that when
it's very easy on the baby's digestive
system that's what i keep here and in
fact gail that's part of the reason why
we went to bobby we liked what was in it
but also eloise is a wonderful baby but
very leaky
and we were getting thrown up on
constantly it was staining things it
smelled terribly and we were looking for
a solution there's the evidence for you
right there
we were looking for some sort of a sony
you all right
that was like the third or fourth of the
day all right i'm in my pajamas but it's
drastically reduced though drastically
drastically reduced uh and so when you
think about why it's easy on the stomach
i mean what what do you come up with uh
at bobby well look it's in the way you
design the recipe so we were able to
match the protein ratio to that of
breast milk flipping the way to casein
i'm not going to get into the deep
science here but it's also like leaving
out ingredients like palm oil which
leads to a lot of constipation and palm
oil is a very common ingredient that you
see in pretty much all u.s formulas you
know the other thing i like about your
story not only do you have such a great
product but i like your back personal
story because you had launched this
company it was going well they did a
piece on you next thing you know fda
agents are showing up at your place with
clipboards you write and you said your
heart
dropped to your stomach never a good
feeling and they not only chose to shut
you down they also issued a recall and
it wasn't because the ingredients were
bad it all had to do with labeling yeah
but laura you did not let that defeat
you that's what i think is so amazing
you did not let that defeat you you
carried on what did you do well
oh well first off hearing you say that
out again it brings all the emotions
back yeah it is such a journey to start
a company right but
there is nothing like being told no to a
group of fiery moms who by the way at
the time i was pregnant saying you know
what no i knew the impact that we could
have on this product is what the u.s
deserved so we kept powering through we
got to get into the shame part of this
that our colleagues
brought up
women feel such pressure to breastfeed
and there's so much shame attached so
much judgment judgment yes
where does that come from well you feel
you have to apologize i remember i would
plan to breastfeed for six months could
only do three and when people ask you
about it it's like you have to apologize
that you didn't make it how do we stop
that shame yes okay
first off no parent and especially a mom
should ever feel guilty about how they
feed their baby period
we did a national survey to find that
two-thirds of parents feel guilty
feeding their babies
two-thirds
and look feeding your baby formula yeah
correct
this might be somewhat controversial to
say this as the ceo of a formula company
i don't believe we need to normalize
formula what we do need to do is
normalize
all types of feeding it's not inclusive
when you think about it the modern
parent today looks very different we're
talking about surrogacy adoption double
mastectomy even just moms who need to go
back to work
the conversation's not inclusive it just
isn't and it leaves you riddled with
that mostly i think internal guilt and
judgment tony mentioned that moment
where you found yourself standing in the
aisle trying to figure out what you were
going to feed your babies we've been
reporting on the struggle to find
formula right now what is your company
doing to help solve this well look
there's nothing more predictable and
repeatable than infant formula right you
guys know once you start you got to keep
going and being a direct to consumer
business a subscription company allows
you to get the product wherever you need
it whenever you need it and i think the
other thing i'll say probably more as a
mom and less as a ceo the anxiety that
is now out there across the u.s for
people saying i can't get my baby food
we have to remove this that's crazy yeah
i'm so glad that nate raised the point
about how to get it because that's one
thing kirby likes it's subscription you
don't have to worry about running out
because bobby is always on time where
did the name bobby come from
my daughter my daughter mary she
couldn't pronounce bottle she would
always say i want my bobby
and it was too cute i couldn't correct
her so it was just a very natural fit
and i also love that if you squint just
a little it sort of looks like booby
booby also works booby also work too but
congrats to you right the subscription
model is great there's nothing worse
than being 11 pm and you realize you got
nothing for the morning and then you're
like googling 24 hour shops
it's raining out it's cold
it's so true never happens with bobby
thank you laura for coming in i detected
a slight irish accent that's right yeah
from the west of ireland slowly fading
but oh no no and i have to say this the
company was founded by moms it was yes
it was yeah very very proud and we're
now a big fiery team of moms moms that
had lots of babies and nowhere nothing
like passionate moms american style
formula it's american style now thank
you very much